what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so it is officially almost the end
of January which means it is now time
for us to begin the process of getting
back into regular video uploads for
those you guys who are new to my channel
January is the one time of year when I
get to basically wind down and relax and
slow down on video uploads yes people
always complain no I do not listen to
them so having said that we are getting
into x-men disassembled now x-men
disassembled is it's interesting it
almost feels like an old Chris Claremont
story that was one of the big things
about marvel fresh start is I think mom
was trying to kind of recapture the way
the comics used to be back in like the
80s and 90s the reality is that that was
lightning in a bottle I don't know if
you can ever really recapture that but
it's cool to see a try so we have like
at Brits in and we've got Rosenberg and
then we have a whole bunch of people who
were in this trying to essentially write
it all together and create this cool the
school set of events but in any event
what this does is it initially picks up
with Jean Grey right now that's one of
the things to bear in mind is ever since
x-men read and ever since Marvel's done
this whole kind of fresh start
initiative Jean Grey is kind of the main
focal point so she's really essentially
more of like a stand-in for Charles
Xavier during the current run of x-men
comics and the way that's played out or
why this plays out rather is she's
basically you know receives a vision of
Jaime madrix who is supposed to be dead
and then like this vision basically
shows like all these x-men kind of going
ballistic and killing like all these
versions of Jaime all of whom are
basically asking where Kitty Pryde is
and so that's what these kind of become
a little mysterious because right off
the bat for somebody to bombard Jean
Grey with such a powerful psychic vision
means they have to be someone who's
equally powerful to her and if that's
the case it's someone to be taken
seriously which means the visions are to
be taken seriously and that's when Jean
starts asking the question she's kind of
like well why in the world are we
looking for Kitty Pryde now switching
over to kitty proper in North Carolina
as they're piloting the jet to go face
off against some d-list villains really
more training for you know like pixie
and armor and really some of the newer
or less experienced x-men in the middle
of all this cape rides powers are
basically taken over in the sense that
she's essentially forced to like face
through the black bird which schwarz it
out now somebody's seizing control of
Kitty Pryde and then controlling her
ability to face through matter is
important because what it means is we're
dealing with someone who can seize
control the powers of others and that's
a pretty big deal like that's that's a
pretty big thing with regards to kitty
and they're true basically running into
these various villains and facing off
against them there's not a whole lot
going on here it's really just kind of
showing what they're doing at the time
now one of the things that ends up
happening is that in the middle of all
this Jaime mad Rock shows up the
multiple man shows up and simply asked
where's kitty pryde and the ottoman
responses kitty vanish which means that
now jamie madrix is too late now with
regards to Jamie mad rocks
he's always basically been kind of a
background character or at least has
been fill ass like decade and a half
really like before the events of house
of am going into house of him and the
aftermath of house of him when he was
running essentially in in was it h
factored the new x-factor comics uh he
was a background character x-factor was
really more of like X Factor
investigations so it's really more of
like a you know private investigator
sort of faction firm and Marvel did
their best to kind of write him in when
they actually did the events with like
going into the future and the events
leading up to like Messiah Complex and
Messiah War and all that kind of cool
stuff but to see a Jamie thrown in such
a way to where he's kind of a person
that's plain like the role of cable is
interesting because in Marvel Comics
whenever Marvel wants to fix something
using time travel they invoke cable
cable shows up and says all man like we
have to fix this one thing that's gonna
happen and you know it basically saves
the future or something along those
lines but Jamie's kind of playing that
role here the differs is that we don't
really know what's going on with Jamie
we're not really sure what's taking
place here all we know is that something
seems to have been going on in the
future and Jamie's seeking to prevent it
now with regards to like the the
involvement of like the old Chris
Claremont method of storytelling this
one we started to get into senator
Ashton Alan now Ashton Allen is wholly
new introduced into this segment but for
those of you guys who are reading x-men
for a long long time he's very
reminiscent of Senator Robert Kelly it's
not really that heavy-handed so much as
it is him basically stepping up and
saying there's a cure for the mutant for
the mutant gene now now the introduction
of a cure is really more like a
background thing at least it seems to be
at this particular point in time it's
designed to set the stage for like how
the world views mutants coming after the
events of the the last word we did were
Cassandra Nova went crazy and basically
you know the the x-men read storyline
basically but in the middle of all this
suddenly jimmy manderach's pops up out
of nowhere and jimmy manderach's kind of
starts going on this spiel and ranting
and raving about how like mutants you
how like there's a threat coming and all
that kind of gets tough you know and so
on and so forth and again it's
interesting to see but it's kind of
building its character up the difference
is that in the middle of all this
suddenly were met by like this massive
army of multiple men all of whom show up
now the funny thing is that there's a
handful of things that happen here all
at the same time I mean the x-men
responding doing the best they can
basically showing people that hey we're
here to protect you not really to harm
you there is some you know instances
here people kind of like what we don't
really know if we should trust you or
not but the big thing about this is in
the middle of it all
Warren Worthington basically least like
Angel just flies off he like he here's a
here's like some disembodied voice and
then flies away and so that's why things
get a little bit crazy because in the
middle of all that Senator Ashton Allen
vanishes as well and so what we end up
doing is picking up with Kitty Pryde
after she'd been taken Senator Ashton
Allen after he had been taken and when
the questions asked what's going on here
and what the heck is happening
we're met by the fact that someone's
managed to capture apocalypse apocalypse
is a demigod right like this this is a
super powerful being I mean apocalypse
is by all standards of measurement a
virtually unstoppable being but the
other thing is that at the same time
this is happening suddenly like these
extinct animals dinosaurs are like
popping up in cities all over the place
there's these strange wetter weather
powders that are taking place around the
world and that's why people are
beginning to begin to sort of panic and
that's why they're trying to figure out
what in the heck is going on as far as
yet return concerned it's like the end
times now following this you end up
having multiple like you know having
like a whole bunch of the group
basically locating multiple man Jimmy
mad rocks and then facing off against
them but again what they're looking for
is Jimmy mad rocks prime the the
original version by which all these
multiple duplicates come from and so
once they find him they can basically
like either taken out and capacitate him
whatever the case is and all the
duplicates will essentially vanish or at
least that seems to be what they're
shooting for here in the middle of all
that while that's happening you end up
jumping back to to the Xavier Institute
proper and the group's met with the
arrival of Legion so like a lot of
things are happening here very very very
fast and this is one of the reasons why
people are kind of looking at the
current uncanny x-men series of stories
and they're looking at like the number
of titles that have been dropped and
they're really kind of coming to the
stance there's too much happening too
fast
there's not really enough enough time
for anybody to catch their breath you
know it's almost kind of like Marvel's
trying to play catch up with like all
the terrible writing they've done with
x-men before and like trying to make up
for it with you know this is this run of
uncanny x-men but again like Legion
showing up here and speaking to this new
mutants for lack of a better word
they're not really experienced with the
character of Legion they don't really
know how to handle him and that's one of
the things that he's kind of betting on
here is when he shows up and says hey
look I'm here to help you guys like I'm
here to fix things you know in the
middle of all that suddenly like his
mind kind of begins to go awry and then
suddenly he seems to sort of snap and
then basically reverts back to his
previous self now for David holler and
in for the character of Legion he has
over the years been more of an enemy of
the x-men than an actual friend and a
lot of this has been due to the fact
that one he's insane two he's got
multiple personalities and three
as he tries to fix things but sort of
screws things up in the process but with
regards to this new generation of x-men
they're totally incapable of facing off
in successfully defeating Legion just
because of the vast amount of power he
possesses I mean you're talking about
like an Omega level telepath and Omega
level telekinetic and that's just Legion
you're talking about like all these
different aspects of Legion that make
him wildly dangerous so these young kids
really don't stand much of a chance here
and that shows itself the funny thing is
that when the rest of the x-men are
called in and they essentially arrive at
the Xavier Institute to face off against
Legion again it's not much of a battle
here because Legion is just so powerful
he's able to hold his own against them
all they're not really able to take him
out and that's what he sounds like I'm
here to save you all when the question
is asked who are you saving us from the
response is I'm saving you from them and
that's when we essentially get like the
horsemen of life The Blob Frank Dux we
get Magneto we get the new angel and
then we get Omega Red now for these
characters again this is somewhat new
territory here in the sense that I mean
these guys are normally villains with
the exception of Angel they're normally
bad guys and they're certainly not
usually the henchmen of other people for
the fact remains with Magneto showing up
and essentially this kind of like going
crazy and like taking out the entirety
of the Xavier Institute what seems to be
going on is exactly what we would expect
with people who become horsemen and this
is when we transition to what seems to
really be going on here that the
horsemen of life are basically serving
the x-man Nate gray now this is kind of
a big revelation because when Nate gray
makes his debut it makes his appearance
to Kitty Pryde and to senator Ashton and
even to apocalypse for the most part
they're familiar with his character
senator Ashton is not he has no idea who
who Nate gray is the difference is that
Nate Gray's been gone for quite some
time and so for him to suddenly make an
appearance here people don't you know
they don't really know how to handle
this now Nate gray was a character who
came out of the story Age of Apocalypse
right so the way that's played out is
again kind of referencing referencing
Legion quest that David holler had come
up with the idea that he could kill
magneto before he ever rose to power to
become a villain the result was that
Xavier jumped in the way of the killing
blow and Charles Xavier died when that
happened it modified the entire time
stream that Apocalypse witnessing the
events unfolding chose that moment to
basically implement his conquest for
world domination and then successfully
took over North America but Nate gray
was a character who was created by mr.
sinister and the way this played out was
it sinister in the main Marvel Universe
and even the time of of age apocalypse
always believed that if if Cyclops
and and Jean Grey were to have a
Pech I would be crazy powerful the gist
of this was that during the Age of
Apocalypse sinister wanted to create
basically you know genetically modify an
engineer a child that could successfully
destroy apocalypse and in his reign and
so he created Nate gray and Nate gray is
a super high-level um he's a
ridiculously powerful character and
almost every way we're actually gonna
find out here is he's more powerful now
than he's ever been before
I mean his his telepathy and telekinesis
was on a scale hitherto unrivaled at the
time him showing back up here is really
anybody's guess in terms of why it's
happening but it's intriguing but what
is up happening here is is he basically
sits down and he says like the world
needs to understand why I'm here
and the world needs to know what my
mission is and so doing something that
no telepath on earth has ever done
before
Nate gray reaches out to the mind of
every single being on the planet now
it's an interesting scenario here
because in reality legion seems to be
the only one who truly knows what's
going on with regards to x-man Nate gray
but he's not really telling anybody
what's happening instead he's kind of
taking the stance of like I have a plan
and I needed the I need Jimmy madrix who
were to actually keep my plan but in
reality you guys just kind of have to
trust me now the other half of this is
that when it came to Jaime being tied up
and having duplicates forced out of
himself
that was legion doing that legion it had
essentially taken over the mind of Jaime
madrix and then forced him to create a
whole bunch of duplicates and sent those
duplicates forward again it was all for
the purpose of trying to find a way to
defeat defeat x-man but again you know
legions kind of keeping it pretty
hush-hush and so when he approaches made
by Jaime after you know he's basically
released and he's he's kind of you know
nursed back when the approach is made
hey like we need your help we need you
to help us with Legion of course the
response to Jaime is absolutely not I
don't want to have anything to do with
that guy like it's because of that guy
that I was tortured essentially like
mentally tortured and and forced to have
duplicates create it because it's what
he wanted to do but again it's kind of
crazy here because when it comes to the
horsemen of life unlike the Horsemen of
Apocalypse which basically see to sow
chaos into reap war what the horsemen of
life look to do is essentially stop
conflict the difference is that they do
it very heavy-handed for example like
there is a a territory like a war-torn
territory that magneto and his guys go
into and then disarm everybody and so
when the x-men show up you're talking
about people who have been fighting for
decades and decades and decades who will
continue to fight even if it's only with
rocks and sticks and so when the x-men
step in to kind of try to curtail the
the entire threat which ultimately leads
to a fight Magneto's response is it's
time for you guys
to leave which ultimately of course
leads into a fight between Polaris and
Magneto himself but it's interesting to
see here we know with these guys facing
off against each other because you're
talking about magneto who's the master
of magnetism now Polaris is nothing to
scoff at she's very powerful in her own
right but when you take magneto as he
exists now with his powers presumably
being amplified well then I would argue
Polaris wouldn't really seem to stand a
whole a whole lot of a chance and that's
exactly what seems to take place here
but these horsemen facing off against
the x-men the fight really kind of seems
to end quick fast and in a hurry
although each member of the of the of
the horsemen is taken out in their own
right now of course this also coincides
with what Nate Grey's doing when Nate
grey has apocalypse and Kitty Pryde
chained up they're basically designed to
represent different aspects of of
society apocalypse represents like
survival of the fittest right like those
who were deemed worthy of living Kitty
Pryde is kind of on the side of the
mutants and then you've got senator
Ashton who's on the side of humanity
and so it was really kind of a I guess a
ragtag makeshift Council that's been
constructed by Nate gray in order to
kind of do what's best to essentially
fix the world and when the statements
made by apocalypse if you really fancy
yourself a god and if you really believe
that you can bring peace to this world
then the first thing you have to do is
give people a reason to believe you're
the one true god and the only way to do
that is to eliminate their faith in any
other gun and so that's exactly what
Nate gray does Nate gray uses his powers
and essentially like wipes from
existence all other temples and and
various statues and so on that are there
for any other God that exists
essentially like wiping all other gods
out of the minds of humanity except for
himself now this is kind of bonkers when
it came to make gray his ability to
manipulate and really to use his powers
his telekinesis always kind of toyed on
the idea that he could manipulate me on
the molecular structure of matter what
this is doing seems to be confirming it
that if he can not only erase these
physical constructs but also erase their
knowledge from the minds of humanity
then in turn like you're talking about
somebody who legitimately is on a god
level like he's Marvel's god mutant
essentially again while that's going on
you've got leading you got the new the
new generation of mutants or
what-have-you who are basically kind of
reconstructing cerebro and where Nate
gray has always been exceedingly good at
hiding himself from anyone who's a
telepath meaning if they're if they're
telepathic they simply won't be able to
find him cerebro not only it seems to
analyze people based on their mutant
patterns but also they're sort of
vibrational frequency now vibrational
frequencies with regards to you know
mutant powers is really kind of a new
concept here it's not
has been around for a long time cerebro
you know cerebro and the version after
its cerebra always kind of existed was
like hey there's a mutants signature
there and we detect them by virtue of
like the X gene that exists inside their
body what this seems to be doing is kind
of introducing the idea that like every
being every being vibrates at a kind of
vibrational frequency but the the
frequency of x-man is unique because
he's not native to this universe and so
it's like having a pile of white blocks
and then you throw a red one in there
well of course the red one's gonna stand
out like a sore thumb unless you were
like colorblind
for those who know how to look for nay
gray they can find him and legion is
someone who can't but again like he
seems to be very ambiguous here and
seems to be kind of fighting for
somewhat of a villainous cause and
that's why things were a little a little
strange when it comes to his characters
because we don't know exactly what his
motivation is but when you switch over
to Psylocke and then you have her
essentially trying to talk to Warren
Worthington one of the things to bear in
mind is Warren Worthington mentally has
been through a lot over the years
originally he was just angel he was just
part of the original x-men and then
eventually he was he was you know well
at least had his rings blown off his
body and then taken he was taken by
apocalypse and then apocalypse offered
to quote-unquote heal him and then in
turn turned him into like the horseman
death by warping his mind and it took
years and years and years and years for
him to kind of regain his bearings but
in one fell swoop when when Betsy
Braddock goes through and takes her
psychic sword and literally slashes at
him what she ends up doing is basically
waking up the evil persona of Warren
Worthington she effectively brings back
the version of him that's known as arc
angel for those people who are really
really familiar with this character this
is exciting for those people who don't
know who it is
they probably don't have a reason to
care but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to come this explain make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the robb core if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
you